quietly invisibly it is now spreading
across the country mortgage misery for
Millions as interest rates ratchet
higher and with the bank of England
lifting them even quicker than expected
the pressure is increasing not
diminishing
certainly the case for Harold who's
about to refix his mortgage the
repayments could be bigger than his
monthly pay I am really worried about it
but my plan is if I don't grow interest
only or they can't move me to interest
only
then I will have to unfortunately sell
where I live it's actually causing me a
lot of anxiety so you know sleeping at
night isn't great I wake up numerous
times it's playing on my mind all the
time my children are now also feeling it
interest rates are a blunt tool that
hurt as much as they cure but they are
the main tool the bank of England has as
it tries to get ahead of inflation
rather than behind it
it was not supposed to be like this
inflation was supposed to be coming down
and fast interest rates were supposed to
be at their Peak now there will be many
postmortems about whether this place got
it wrong but for the time being the big
question is whether it can bring
inflation under control and what that
means for the rest of us
that means a tough time for borrowers
less so for Savers and for those whose
wages are going up the governor has a
message for you too we cannot continue
to have the current level of wage
increases and we can't can't have
companies seeking to rebuild profit
margins which means prices continue to
go up at their current rates but what I
would say to people is we expect
inflation to come down
and it's important then that price
setting and wage setting reflects that
because the current levels I'll be
absolutely honest are unsustainable
and it's not just households businesses
like this Pub here are already feeling
the impact most corporate loans and
Facilities already reflect higher
borrowing costs interest rates are
putting pressure on us in terms of
repayment plans and everything else so
our costs have got like massively wage
costs are also costly going up based on
the lack of Supply we really need to
mainly put our prices up at times
otherwise we can't stay afraid it's
really tough at the moment and it's
scary for the cost of everything at the
moment
in short it's pain of many different
dimensions and pain which won't end
anytime soon the disease of inflation is
afflicting the UK economy the medicine
being doled out by the bank is almost as
unpleasant Ed Conway Sky News